pour pour commencer par le commencement
ce choix quand on est un jeune acteur
n'existe pas elle n'existe pas assez
compréhensible parce que quand on débute
on est tellement heureux qu'on me
propose un rôle qu'on se précipite
dessus qu'ils soient bons ou mauvais
dans un bon film dans un mauvais film
parce que cela vous donne l'occasion de
d'apprendre son métier de l'exercer et
de prendre contact avec le public
par conséquent un jeune comédien ne
choisit pas alors rentrer pour lui en
jeu le facteur chance
en ce qui me concerne je crois avoir eu
au début de chance extraordinaire
la première c'est de ne pas avoir on a
fait j'ai commencé à travailler en 41 et
je tourne et jj aux 48 j'ai donc eu sept
ans pendant lesquels j'ai pu faire des
petits rôles au théâtre au cinéma sans
que personne ne remarque et par
conséquent sans que personne ne me
jugent ce qui est très pratique pour
faire ses classes et peut-être quand on
est venu me proposer g j étais je plus
en possession de mon métier je l'étais
certainement plus que si on me l'avait
proposé au bout de six mois ou d'un an
de travail
donc c'est aimer de chance
ensuite quand gj m'a été proposée par
jacques innodry vraiment pour une
débutante que j'étais de vous donner à
la fois un rôle en or parce que j étais
un rôle en or et cède ensuite de vous
donner un texte de colette une oeuvre de
caunes est mise en scène par un metteur
en scène qui l'avait compris et qui est
capable de pénétrer une oeuvre de ce
grand écrivain parfaitement l de
traduire un email
et en plus de me donner comme partenaire
et 22 bray et gaby morlay vraiment où se
réunit c'est vraiment très rare et je
crois que j'ai été très gâté
ce furent mes premières larmes au cinéma
mais en définitif elle me procurèrent
bien de la joie et je ne peux que
m'associer aux millions de jeunes qui
ont été eu parce que la taille cris g j
étais un rôle en or et je vous assure
que n'importe quelle comédienne ce n'est
pas de la modestie de ma part que de me
dire devait obtenir un succès avec un
rôle pareil d'ailleurs la suite l'a
prouvé
un acteur ne peut se défendre quand
fonction de ce qu'on lui donne à
défendre quand on lui donne un bon rôle
sa tâche est beaucoup plus facile
donc le public est venu voir j j et tout
en n'étant pas l'entière responsable
luan là j'en ai en tout cas été
l'heureuse bénéficiaire cas je veux bien
vous dire que si vous ces publics qui
donne qui accorde cette liberté de choix
dont je vous parle à l'acteur en venant
voir le film qu'il vient de tourner ou
en ne venant pas parce que c'est le test
pour un producteur c'est l'argument le
plus pesant le plus probant quand il
songe à engager une actrice c'est de se
dire est bien celle là elle est
commerciale en vient la voir
ou bien elle n'est pas commercial et à
ce moment là on engage plus
difficilement st
quelquefois faire la part des
possibilités qu'on lui a damné des
lettres ou de n'être pas donc c'est vous
qui décidez mais vous me direz vous ne
pouvez décider qu en fonction de ce
qu'on vous touche et vous ne pouvez être
touchés qu'à travers d'histoires qu'un
auteur vous propose l'acteur site une
grande part mais il ne vient qu'après
voilà vous dit on verra bien pourquoi un
acteur ne choisit pas toujours une bonne
histoire
pourquoi ne choisit t-il pas toujours de
tourner un très bon film avec un très
bon metteur en scène et oui pourquoi
mais vous savez ça ce n'est pas si
facile
ce n'est pas si facile parce que tout
acteur bien sûr choisir est de tourner
en priorité avec charlie chaplin ou avec
un éclair et moi dont seulement voilà
charlie chaplin il rené clair faut-il
encore qu'il vous demande vous choisi et
cela n'arrive pas toujours et
quelquefois même pas une seule fois
pendant toute une longue carrière d'un
très bon comédien
alors quoi faire
il faut bien se décider il faut bien
faire son métier
dulin disait qu'une des chances le plus
extraordinaire cave est un peintre était
que quand il avait fait une toile
accepte mal ne vous plaisait pas il
avait toujours la ressource de la
retourner contre le mur pour nous ce
n'est pas possible il faut pour faire
notre métier que le rideau se lève et
que vous soyez là on joue pas seul la
comédie
quoi qu il soit de bataille était
publique que un acteur et sublime tout
seul à sa chambre à coucher ou dans sa
salle de bains moi je suis formidable
tout seul quand la caméra trône au camp
rideau se lève c'est autre chose